The solutions that we described on
how to virtualize memory in inode
clearly indicate that there is
some degree of complexity and
overhead that have to be incurred
by the due to virtualization.
Given the wide recognition that
virtualization delivers important
benefits and it's been pointed out
earlier in this lesson in that it
presented an important path to address
some of the issues related to rising
operating costs in the IT industry.
The hardware companies responded and
they modified their architectures
in a way that makes them more
appropriate for virtualization.
In the x86 world these virtualization
friendly architectures
started appearing around 2005.
Read AMD Pacifica and Intel Vanderpool
Technology or LIntel-VT for short.
With respect to x86, so one of the first
things that was fixed was to close
the holes with respect to those 17
non-virtualizable instructions, so
that they will cause a trap and
pass control over in a privileged mode.
Also, the new protection
mode was introduced.
So, as opposed to having just one
protection mode with four ranks,
now there are two protection modes,
so root and non-root.
Also referred to as host because this is
the route is the mode in which the host
operating system, the hypervisor
would run and the non route,
that's also referred to as guest which
is where the guest VM would run.
Also, a support was added for
the processor,
the hardware processor to understand and
to be able to interpret information
that describes the state of
the virtual processors called VCPUs.
This information is captured
in a VM Control Structure or
also called a VM control block
in the AMD x86 architectures.
The fact that the hypervisor understands
how to interpret this data, so
it can walk this data structure
is the term that's commonly used.
Means that it can specify whether or
not a system call should trap.
So, it's easy for
the hypervisor to know that a particular
type of operation should not
cause a trap into root mode and
instead should be handled by the
privilege layer in the non-root mode, so
the privilege layer in the non-root
mode is the operating system.
Then other pieces of information,
then that in a certain way can help
reduce the virtualization overhats.
The next step in terms of virtualization
related advances was to make it
easier to manage memory.
Since hardware was already able to
understand the presence of different
VMs, the next step here involved
tagging the memory structures used by
the hypervisor with
the corresponding VM identifiers.
So this led to support for extended
page tables where the page table entries
now include information about
the VMI team and also tagged TLBs.
What this means is that if there is a
context switch am, among VMs that's also
called the world switch, when we're
switching from one VM to another.
We don't have to flush or
invalidate those entries that are in
the TLB that belong to the previous VM.
This is because the MMU,
when it performs a check against
the TLB entries will try to match
both the virtual address that is
causing the access request as
well as the VM identifier.
And if they both match,
then it will proceed with the address
that's specified in the TLB entry.
Otherwise, it will deal with
the page fault failures.
As a result, context switches
are now much more efficient.
Hardware was also extended to add better
support for IO virtualization and
this included modifications both to
the processor and the chipset side.
And also device and system interconnect
capabilities that were introduced in
order to support this.
Some examples of these features include
things like multiqueue capabilities on
the device and you can think of this
as the device having multiple logical
interfaces where each interface
can be used by a separate VM.
And also better support
of interrupt routing, so
that when a device needs to deliver an
interrupt to a specific VM, it actually
interrupts the core where that VM is
executing and not some other CPUs.
Additional virtualization related
hardware features were also included for
stronger security guarantees that
now can be made to the VMs and
also to protect VMs from one another
as well as from the hypervisor.
And also, features for better management
support or for more efficiently to be
able to perform various management
operations in virtualized environments.
You can think of this as
more virtualization friendly
management interfaces.
Also, a number of new instructions
were added to x86 in order to actually
exercise all of these new features.
For instance,
a new instruction was introduced to
transition from one mode to another.
Basically, to transition from root mode
or to return control to non-root mode.
Or a new instructions to
manipulate in certain ways
state that's in the per VM
control data structure, etc.